et avec nous ce soir alexis poulain
éditorialistes bonsoir à vos côtés éric
verhaeghe essayiste fondateur du blog le
courrier des stratèges bonsoir alexandre
del valle géopolitologue spécialiste des
relations entre l'europe et la turquie
et du monde arabo-musulman est également
avec nous ce soir bonsoir messieurs
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors avant l'hommage à samuel
pâtit votre réaction concernant ces
derniers éléments de l'enquète c'est
donc le parquet national anti terroriste
qui est saisi le procureur à relayer
toute la chaîne qui s'est mise en place
avant l'attentât et deux collégiens de
14 et 15 ans déférés pour avoir désigné
le professeur à l'assaillant ils ont été
soudoyé un par le terroriste contre une
somme d'argent
alexandre del vals comment on en est
arrivé là aujourd'hui
en fait vous savez c'est quelque chose
de mondial ont commis le terrorisme au
niveau international il se passe la même
chose dans ce genre de quartier ou de
lycée que ce qui se passe lorsque
quelqu'un est pris en otage ou
assassinés au mali au burkina faso en
irak
c'est très courant il y a plusieurs
chaînes de transmission de l'information
il ya des gens qui sont pas hispanique
mais qui ont été payées pour dire où
habite le le toubab quand ces homos
burkina faso où l occidentale où le
croiser des camps c'est quelque chose
qui se passe en irak et après le parfois
l'otage est vendu à plusieurs
organisations non on retrouve le même
phénomène chez nous finalement les gens
qui sont pas forcément dans la doctrine
mais ils ont donné des informations un
petit peu parce qu'ils n'aiment pas les
blasphémateurs avec eux dans les
banlieues cas quelqu'un de la police de
lyon me disait l'autre jour que il a
assisté à un délit à à des réjouissances
il a bu mais bande des jeunes qui sont
pas par des militants islamistes mais
lisez finalement il a bien cherché
donc il ya un mélange de vénalité de
voyoucratie parce que y aussi des liens
avec les milieux royoux 1 pour se
procurer des armes et il ya un mélange
aussi le n de radicalisme islamiste
n'est pas que et donc c'est quelque
chose c'est un mot ghz
indiquons retrouve à l'international
comme chez nous il se reproduit chez
nous des phénomènes que l'on observe
dans des hauts lieux du djihadisme ça
veut dire aujourd'hui que cette question
on doit la règle et avec nos voisins à
l'international oui mais pas au sens où
on pourrait le croire pas au sens de la
répression
moi j'ai écrit un article dans valeurs
actuelles récemment où je rappeler
quelque chose que rappelle les militants
modéré laïque du monde musulman mais il
faut le rappeler parce qu'on le dit
jamais assez le blasphème est condamné à
mort est puni de mort dans plusieurs
pays musulmans
il est puni de mort dans la charia même
en france
partout on enseigne la charia il y a des
chapitres sur la façon de tuer les
homosexuels les juifs les mécréants les
païens les prosélytes croiser des
chrétiens ou les blasphémateurs et dans
le monde musulman le grand combat ddd
des intellectuels modérés
vous savez quel est le grand combat
c'est contre le blasphème parce que la
punition de blasphème et ce qui pourrit
la vie du monde musulman et des libres
penseurs
donc on retrouve chez nous quelque chose
qui se passe au niveau de l'islam
mondial pourquoi
regardez ce qui s'est passé à l asa ces
jours ci la plus grande université du
sunnisme
c'est pas le djihadisme c'est l'egypte
c'est la plus grande université depuis
des siècles du monde sunnite
elle vient de dire que le meilleur moyen
pour qu'ils aient pas ce genre
d'assassinât par décapitation en france
ce serait d'interdire tout blasphème et
de pénaliser ce que les 57 pays
musulmans de l'organisme de
l'organisation de la conférence
islamique demande depuis les années 90
c'est que ils appellent ça diffamation
l'ordre et les jeunes que l'on pénalise
toute critique de l'islam et ils vont y
arriver un jour ou l'autre
parce que les mots des rivaux 10 c'est
pour pâques et de meurtres et les
djihadistes vous disent attention on va
vos buts et si vous vous propose ici si
vous faites si vous pratiquez le
blasphème donc le problème ne sera réglé
que lorsque les grandes instances de
l'islam du monde entier comme el azhar e
cesseront de se référer à une
jurisprudence qui n'a rien à voir avec
la foi
je précise la fois du bon
durant les cinq piliers de ne passe pas
nécessairement par l'application d'aidé
par exemple en arabie saoudite au lieu
des 2 les lieux saints et pays du
salafisme en crucifie les blasphémateurs
apostats ça se pratique aujourd'hui et
c'est pas des chaussées les lieux saints
de l'islam le salafisme il faut savoir
qu'on a dit plein de bêtises dans les
médias ces jours ci c'est pas des
hérétiques de l'islam c'est le quatrième
courant officielle de l'islam sunnite
qui est reconnu par l'ema liquide qui
est reconnu par lazard et donc l'islam a
besoin d'une réforme pour dépénaliser au
moins qu on ne punit pas de morts ce
genre de choses parce que tant que ce
sera écrit dans les textes qu'on
enseigne dans nos mosquées
comment voulez vous qu'un djihadistes ne
passent pas à l'acte et je termine sur
une chose le patron des frères musulmans
dans toute l'europe qui a fini en sur
rue les organisations comme lui au
relief musulmans de france où le caër
aux états unis leurs grands juristes de
référence a écrit un livre que vous
pouvez acheter à la fnac et sur amazon
qui n'a jamais été interdit et il vous
explique un musulman peut tuer pour
trois raisons l'adultère la fosse tard
et celui qui blasphème donc la sas à
l'assassinât des journalistes de charlie
hebdo est tout à fait charia tic et il
est permis par des organisations comme
les frères musulmans qu'ils écrivent
noir sur blanc et c'est pour ça que nous
avons dit à la commission d' enquête sur
la radicalisation du sénat qui a été
très écouté d'ailleurs par l'elysée avec
sifaoui avec d'autres emmanuel razavi
nous avons proposé d'interdire toute
organisation qui se réfère à une ch à
une charia à une lecture de la charia
qui prévoit la peine de mort pour le
blasphème ou l'apostasié pour continuer
avec vous sur l'aspect international
alexandre del vals est ce que des pays
ont contribué selon vous la propagation
du salafisme en france mais bien sûr
déjà il faut savoir que le la ligue
islamique mondiale qui à 2000 mètres
carrés autour de paris dans la région
parisienne et qui à 3000 mètres carrés à
bruxelles où qui a carrément monopolisé
la formation des imams en espagne donc
dans plusieurs pays européens
elle a pignon sur rue cette organisation
l art l aise
c'est le salafisme officiel le salafisme
je le répète c'est pas des hérétiques
c'est le courant officielle du
hanbalisme c'est son vrai nom qui est le
courant officielle en arabie saoudite au
qatar
c'est aussi la référence des frères
musulmans et de nombreux salafistes
pakistanais mêmes turcs eux puisque les
salafistes maintenant une ado dans le
monde entier et 7 salaf isation des
esprits elle a littéralement défiguré le
monde musulman jusqu'en indonésie
vous ne reconnaissez plus certains pays
musulmans des vieilles personnes me
disaient qu'elles ont connues
l'indonésie où l'egypte il ya 50 ans les
pays sont méconnaissables
qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre temps
les frères musulmans et les salafistes
officielle qui se réfère au même courant
handball it on va pas entrer dans les
détails juridiques mais il se réfère à
la même jurisprudence grosso modo et
bien c'est justement eux qui sont pour
un jihad violent
ils veulent rétablir un califat ils ont
une logique suprémacistes ils sont et
ils prônent l'assassinât des juifs des
mécréants
ddd des païens et des blasphémateurs
donc vous voyez bien que ce salafisme il
a été déjà instaurées en europe par des
pays qui avaient pignon sur rue avec
leurs diplomaties leur ambassade
donc il faut bannir tout islamisme qui
prévoit des choses qui sont contraires
aux droits de l'homme et à notre droit
tout court dans les pays occidentaux
et ce sera beaucoup plus facile ensuite
d'interdire des prêcheurs parce que là
on a interdit des mosquées ou des
prêcheurs dans certains endroits pour
les motifs d'hygiène parce qu'ils ont
trouvé que ça mais il suffit qu'ils se
mettent aux normes de l'hygiène et ses
mosquées et ses prêcheurs vont
réapparaître dans un mois ou dans deux
mois ou dans six mois maximum
donc il faut bannir comme on a banni le
nazisme à nuremberg
il faut bannir moralement et
juridiquement l'islamisme radical et on
oublie aussi le troisième le communisme
les trois grandes idéologies
totalitaires devrait être bannie au même
niveau et ce serait plus facile ensuite
d'interdire les groupuscules violents
qui se réfère à ces idéologies alors
pour revenir à lenquête le procureur a
également confirmé que l'assassinât de
sa mère pattie s'inscrivait dans un
contexte d'appel au meurtre un lancer
depuis la rue publication des
caricatures de mahomet par charlie hebdo
début septembre eric verhaeghe on a
beaucoup entendu ces derniers jours
cette volonté montrés massivement ses
caricatures dans les écoles beaucoup de
d'élèves un présent ce soir à l'hommage
de samuel pâtit qu'est ce que vous en
pensez c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui je
pense que nous avons notamment à travers
cette attaque sur un enseignant atteint
un point de rupture
thor dans l'histoire de la réaction de
ce pays al islam est donc dans son
obsession de la lutte contre
l'islamophobie
je pense que s'attaquer à un enseignant
sans doute s'attaquer encore à quelque
chose qui représente la république même
si on peut penser que cette image c'est
un peu de 10 août avec le temps
s'aperçoit que les français ont compris
le danger islamiste sur lequel on alerte
beaucoup alerte depuis plusieurs années
en prêchant dans le vide
d'ailleurs aux dents dans l'indifférence
générale ou parfois quand l'hostilité
d'un certain nombre de frange de
l'opinion notamment à gauche donc on
s'aperçoit qu'on a atteint ce point de
rupture et qu'aujourd'hui une réaction
en profondeur est en train de se
produire qui ressemble à une prise de
conscience vis-à-vis d'un danger qui a
été systématiquement minimiser ou
sous-estimé mounier par un certain
nombre de deux membres de nombre
d'éléments de l'opinion publique la
question est de savoir aujourd'hui
comment on va se matérialiser cette
prise de conscience et cette réaction
c'est à dire est ce que l'opinion
française est capable de dépasser le
stade de l'émotion ou à ce soir et est
ce que les pouvoirs publics
est-ce que notamment l'état régalien est
capable aujourd'hui de ta d'adopter les
grands éléments les grands axes que
vient de citer alexandre del valle
c'est-à-dire d'abord un renversement
d'alliances internationales puisque
c'est vrai que nous sommes très
dépendants du qatar de l'arabie saoudite
qui sont des grands financeurs salafisme
est ce qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes alliés
de ces puissances de ces pays
de ces intervenants internationaux
depuis les années 70 notamment dans la
foulée de la guerre en afghanistan est
ce que les pouvoirs publics sont
aujourd'hui capables de renverser cette
alliance est d'imposer aux financeurs
saoudien aux financeurs qatari un
certain nombre de règles du jeu ce qu'il
faut comprendre aujourd'hui c'est que
lorsque les cathares ont acheté le paris
saint germain est donc financer
massivement
c'était une sorte de cheval de trois
sets à deux chevaux de troie qui a fait
le lit du salafisme et de l'islamisme en
france cette dépendance financière qui a
des côtés très bling bling se traduit
aussi par une logique politique
totalement toxiques pour les libertés
publiques et pour l'idéologie république
et nous avons ce sujet en france
aujourd'hui c'est parce que nous sommes
prêts à tirer toutes les conséquences
radicales de la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
nos banlieues sont très largement
investie par une vision salafistes quête
orthogonale complètement en conflit avec
les grandes valeurs républicaines qui
nous ont faits qui ont fait notre
civilisation depuis cherchait alors
justement avant de vous entendre alexis
poulain voici les mots du chef de l'état
relayée par le canard aux anges en
lequel a enchaîné c'était en privé après
le conseil de défendu 18 octobre
regarder l'ennemi est clairement
identifiée il veut notre mort nous
allons donc livrer un combat à mort la
république est bonne fille mais elle ne
se laissera pas violer si nous ne
prenons pas ce combat à bras le corps
viendra le temps difficiles des
affrontements et des milices nous allons
décapiter les organismes islamistes
alexis poule à cet attentat est ce que
vous croyez est ce que vous observez de
la part du politique
un tournant aujourd'hui dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme islamiste
oui c'était espérer on a l'impression
que enfin la classe politique prend
conscience de l'ampleur du désastre
classe politique hautement coupable
d'avoir été clientéliste d'avoir fermé
les yeux d'avoir accompagné en fait
c'est ça la fixation des territoires par
intérêt tout personnel et aucun
politique aujourd'hui on est en mesure
de pointer le doigt vers un autre en
disant qu'il n'a rien fait et y compris
le rassemblement national qui a accepté
un prêt de l'arabie saoudite pour se
financer donc c'est vous dire comment
toute la classe politique française est
dépendante de l'argent des
pétromonarchies et dépendantes et y
compris ici sur le territoire pour
garder ses sièges et ses électeurs d'une
certaine frange de d'un islamisme qui se
présente sous des associations sous des
atours acceptable mais qui derrière
prêche une idéologie totalement
antagonistes avec les valeurs de la
république liberté égalité et fraternité
et ça c'est important que la prise de
conscience soit faite
on aurait aimé que samuel pâtit soit
épargné qu'il soit protégé par la
république quand pharos avait reçu le
signalement du compte twitter de ce
terroriste en juillet peut-être que
certaines certains outils aurait dû être
mis en place à ce moment-là que
l'éducation nationale aussi aurait dû
être vent debout derrière son professeur
en rejetant les appels de ses parents
d'élèves qui cherchait à faire entrer
par la petite porte
leur foi dans l'école de la république
pour imposer une vision de la liberté
d'expression qui n'a rien à voir encore
une fois avec nos lois avec la façon
dont ici nous disons
comment critiquer les religions nous
avons le droit de blasphémer
heureusement donc tout ça c'est des
années voilà d'un laxisme total qui
aujourd'hui arrivent à maturité avec la
la fois la récurrence de ses attentats
sur notre sol ce n'est pas la première
décapitation il y avait eu d'autres
attentats de cette façon là ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'on cible un
professeur ou une école c'était à
toulouse c'était meira c'était en 2012
donc vous voyez toutes ces années n'ont
pas été mis à profit pour en finir avec
le poison islamistes au sein de notre
pays de notre république donc si les
politiques en prennent conscience
aujourd'hui et mettre les politiques
qu'il faut et agissent alors tant mieux
on ne va pas s'en plaindre
alors éric verhaeghe alexis poulain
évoqué l'instant l'éducation nationale
dans quelques instants ce sera le temps
du recueillement avec l'hommage à cet
enseignant samuel pâtit le travail des
professeurs également mis à l'honneur ce
soir
est-ce que l'éducation nationale a été
abandonné par les autorités sur cette
question d'islamisation de l'école éric
verhaeghe
non je pense qu' il faudra une fois le
temps de l'émotion et de la delacourt
doléances passer il faudra quand même
commencer un grand inventaire sur ce qui
se passe à l'éducation nationale alors
d'abord disons le aujourd'hui
l'éducation nationale c'est une place
forte
les pouvoirs politiques des pouvoirs
publics nos plus la légitimité ni la
capacité à intervenir directement sur la
pédagogie la pédagogie qui a fait
sécession dans ce pays il faut le dire
les enseignants aujourd'hui considèrent
qu'ils sont propriétaires de leurs
charges et qu'ils sont seuls maîtres
face à leurs élèves
et il ya une vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui à mettre à plat les
questions de pédagogie ce qu'il va être
intéressant ce sera notamment de faire
l'inventaire
ce qui s'est passé dans l'académie de
versailles autour du professeur tad
pâtit puisqu'un certain nombre de
rumeurs ou d'indications d' indices
laissent à penser que l'académie de
versailles a envoyé des signaux de
soutien relatif aux parents d'élèves qui
se plaignait du professeur paty et des
signaux de désaveu relatif auprès du
professeur pâtit qui a été convoquée
semble-t-il par un inspecteur qui
visiblement lui a demandé d'expliquer sa
façon d'enseigner l'esprit critique et
donc aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya un
vrai sujet c'est à dire que moi j'ai lu
quand même je suis allé sur les sites
des syndicats enseignants
je n'ai vu aucun syndicat enseignant et
notamment le snes fsu qui est le
syndicat majoritaire n'a pas pris
position clairement sur le caractère
islamiste de l'attentât donc aujourd'hui
nous avons des syndicats enseignants qui
sont les premiers à protéger d'islamisme
et qui sont en tout cas les premiers à
minorer le danger islamiste est à dire
il faut pas de récupération etc
nous avons aujourd'hui besoin de savoir
ce qui se passe à l'éducation nationale
de passer sept les murs de cette
forteresse qui nous interdit de
comprendre comment le savoir est
enseignée dans les écoles et nous avons
besoin de savoir comment l'institution
se positionne par rapport à la lutte
contre l'islamisme et de ce point de vue
il faut qu'on n'entame une havre est une
vraie remise à plat de la responsabilité
très profonde en laquelle je crois des
syndicats enseignants dans ce qui s'est
passé je pense qu'on ne peut pas
comprendre la sphère pâtit sans
comprendre qu'il y a des syndicats en
france
enseignants qui sont financés par le
contribuable et qui aujourd'hui font
tout pour que la lutte contre
l'islamisme n'est pas lui et qui passe
aujourd'hui plus de temps à dénoncer
l'islamophobie qu'à défendre les valeurs
de la république et cette phase là elle
doit s'ouvrir très vite une fois le
temps du réellement passé je vous
propose justement à ce sujet d'écouter
un témoignage c'est celui de rodrigo
arenas et le
ce président de la fcpe c'est la
première association de parents d'élèves
et il a reçu un signalement vendredi
dernier faisant état d'un père
extrêmement énervé après la publication
en classe d'une caricature de mahomet
regardez c'est que nous avons signalé
cela au maire au maire pourquoi parce
que nous avons estimé que ce qui était
diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux étaient
suffisamment probants pour nous craindre
un trouble à l'ordre public et dans
notre pays ceux qui sont en charge de
l'ordre public dans une commune ça
s'appelle le maire qui ensuite
évidemment travail avec les services de
police pour éviter les débordements quel
qu'il soit c'est pour cela que j'ai fait
prévenir le maire qui m'a fait a appelé
dans la journée pour me dire que toutes
les dispositions ont été prises sur la
ville de conflans sainte honorine
suite à ça ces messages qui circulait
sur les réseaux sociaux et que
l'éducation nationale parfaitement au
fait des deux de cette situation mettez
tout à disposition toutes les procédures
normales
en tout cas les procédures qui existent
pour ce type de cas c'est que nous avons
signé les cela au maire mais si poulain
effectivement vous vous rejoignez les
propos d'eric verhaeghe qui d'irak qui
disait que une fois le recueillement
l'émotion terminé il faudra s'interroger
aussi sur la position des syndicats de
l'éducation nationale
il faudra s'interroger sur la position
tout le monde bien sûr cette question de
la place des parents dans l'école c'est
pas neuf là encore c'est le progressisme
des années 80 70 comment faire que
l'école soit soit ouverte sur les
parents mais ça ne veut pas dire que les
parents font la loi dans l'école quant
aux syndicats ils sont là pour protéger
les travailleurs donc on aimerait qu'il
protège les travailleurs
ce que j'ai vu c'est beaucoup de
professeurs de syndiqués ou non
très en colère par rapport à la
commisération qu'il y avait maintenant
sur le métier de professeur alors que on
tire à boulet rouge
en temps normal sur ces enseignants trop
feignants qui passent leur temps en
vacances etc etc
rappelez vous on les accusait d'avoir
pris en otage les copies du bac parce
qu'il se plaignait justement il
critiquer la façon dont l'éducation
nationale a été géré mais une fois
encore l'éducation nationale comme
toutes les administrations
est gérée par une boursouflure
administratif qui fait que finalement
c'est là où on a le plus besoin de
ressources qu'il n'y en a pas les
professeurs on a besoin de davantage de
professeurs on a besoin de moins
d'élèves dans les classes on a besoin de
faire en sorte que l'éducation soit de
qualité
mais qu'est ce qui se passe on a des
rectorats on a tout cette boursouflure
administrative qui fait que ce
management par la peur par la protection
des uns des autres on se renvoie
toujours la patate chaude l'idée c'est
d'être jamais responsable jamais
coupable donc on fait tout pour se
protéger que ce soit l'inspecteur puis
le recteur etc etc
dans l'éducation nationale comme dans
beaucoup d'organisation mais là c'est
particulièrement flagrant
les professeurs sont seuls face aux
élèves sont seuls face aux parents et
est rarement rarement très rarement ils
ont le soutien du directeur
d'établissement et de la machine
éducation nationale donc il ya un vrai
travail à faire sur la façon dont tous
toute cette éducation doit être revue
parce que quand même l'éducation
nationale c'est le projet qui fonde
aussi la république sociale sait faire
que tous les citoyens puissent avoir les
moyens de grottes de se grandir
intellectuellement de se cultiver avoir
les moyens pour leur futur préparer leur
futur aujourd'hui la faillite et les
nombreuses à elle et à de nombreuses de
nombreux échelons et ça ne fait que ça
ne fait que continuer je crois que c'est
important que au delà de ce moment où
tout le monde s'arrête pense aux
professeurs à tous les professeurs que
nous avons eues qui nous ont permis de
devenir qui nous sommes aujourd'hui
eh bien il ya une politique derrière qui
va débloquer les moyens alors je sais ça
fait beaucoup de moyens il en faut pour
l'hôpital il faut pour l'éducation
nationale il en faut aussi pour la
police mais voilà ces années qui ont été
celles du moins d'état ce qui ont été
celles du démantèlement de l'état social
de la république sociale elles doivent
cesser aujourd'hui et au delà de la
réponse qui va être une réponse
sécuritaire bien entendu il y a une
réponse de long terme qui est celle de
la devise de la république celle de
l'égalité de la liberté de la fraternité
qui passera par une éducation nationale
qui a les moyens d'éduquer qu'ils aient
les moyens de faire en sorte que l'on
crée des citoyens conscients et pas des
bêtes comme ce tchétchène qui a 18 ans à
une bouillie dans la tête qui lui permet
de décapiter un professeur simplement
parce qu'il a montré des caricatures
alexis poulain eric verhaeghe
vous restez avec nous on va remercier
alexandre
delvallée qui a dû nous quitter
merci à lui on va tout de suite